a brand new spongebob squarepants game
has been announced we now have more
details as to why god of war ragnarok is
going to be the second and final entry
in the norse saga sega is announcing a
brand new rpg at tokyo game show and
mega man's robo dog rush is making his
way to monster hunter rise i'm persia
and this is your gamespot news update
a brand new spongebob squarepants game
was announced during thq nordic's 10th
anniversary live stream spongebob
squarepants the cosmic shake trailer
kicked off with one of the show's most
iconic scenes but quickly revealed that
this game will be revisiting many places
inspired by the series according to the
game's steam page spongebob and patrick
meet the mysterious fortune teller
cassandra who gives them a vial full of
mermaid's tears their overexcitement and
flurry of wishes tear open the very
fabric of space and time and now they
have to save everyone in bikini bottom
sounds about right you can unlock
platforming skills and costumes and even
travel to seven distinct wish worlds
like wild west jellyfish fields and
halloween rock bottom which could point
to gameplay similar to that of battle
for bikini bottom the cosmic shake will
also include your favorite bikini bottom
ites from the series voiced by their
original actors and 101 songs from the
series including sweet victory no
release date has been announced just yet
but i've definitely already put it on my
steam wish list of all 101 songs that
are going to be in the game which one
are you going to listen to first let me
know down below in the comments
god of war ragnarok is the second and
final entry into sony santa monica
studios north saga and now series
veteran corey barlock has shed some
light on why the studio is planning to
wrap things up with the sequel
speaking to captain kuba barlog said
there are several reasons for this the
first of which is that games of this
size and scale simply take a very long
time to make and barlog doesn't want the
saga to drag out too long from the
beginning barlog wanted to tell a story
about kratos and atrius they are the
core of the story's engine as he put it
the complexities that stem from that
relationship have plenty of room to grow
but barlog didn't want to stretch things
too far being able to condense the god
of war norse saga story into two games
is similar to how you could sit down and
watch all of the lord of the rings films
and feel like you were told a complete
story that had a strict beginning and
end barlog also said a two-game arc for
the god of war north saga felt right for
what eric williams the new director had
in mind for the game while ragnarok is
the final entry in the north saga barlog
said he plans to make a big splash with
a different project as his next game
though he didn't share any details
ragnarok is launching in 2022 for ps4
and ps5 and if you want to know even
more about the game then check out our
video that rounds up everything you need
to know about god of war ragnarok
sega will be revealing a brand new rpg
at tokyo game show on october 1st
the teaser trailer for the mobile rpg
shows a feather quill with ink drawing
out the background and some of the
characters that will presumably be in
the game the drawing ends with a
watercolor visual of three characters
overlooking a beautiful vast meadow
there isn't any gameplay footage just a
few screens towards the end of the
trailer depicting someone falling a
woman being stabbed by a mysterious
shadowy figure as well as another with a
sword kneeling on one knee the voiceover
accompanying the trailer translated by
ign japan states that the team behind
this game took inspiration from tabletop
rpgs the game is meant to be an rpg with
player choice on how the story unfolds
more information about this game will be
revealed during sega's presentation at
tokyo game show and that is going to be
on october 1st at 9 00 a.m eastern 6 a.m
pacific
monster hunter rise has introduced a
number of new elements to the series
with one of them being a canine
companion and an upcoming cosmetic swap
for your palamu will make it look like
mega man's robo dog rush the special
event that starts september 24th will
give you crafting materials to make the
rush skin upon completion the trailer
for the palamu event shows footage from
mega man 11 the most recent game in the
long running action platformer series
but rush first appeared in the series in
mega man 3 all the way back in 1990 the
robo canine is a swiss army knife of a
character transforming into vehicles
like a submarine or a jet board however
in monster hunter rise he looks to stay
in his regular dog form albeit carrying
around a massive blade in his jaws
previous special events have given out
other palymute skins like the okami
crossover and there is even one that
lets you look like a kumo from street
fighter
if you want to learn more about today's
topics then all you gotta do is visit
gamespot.com thank you all so much for
watching and we'll catch you next time
[Music]
you